mais d'autres sources tu n'es pas que ce
soit contre un fonctionnaire qui sont
d'accord avec toi ya toi tu parles tu
veux savoir elle est où mais non c'est
bien tu ne m'énerve je vais tenir pas
toujours vraiment mélodies non mais je
connais évidemment évidemment je suis
contre le harcèlement
je suis content le signalement en
revanche dans le cas de millas je pense
qu'il faut arrêter désolé mais de
victimiser cette fille qui passe son
temps à cracher sur toute une communauté
milla mais ce n'est pas une raison pour
la revoilà ses portes du 4 au 6 mai on
en a fait un symbole du cyberharcèlement
faut dire qu'il est aussi plein de
jeunes qui se font harceler et si
barclays gratuitement à cause de leur
physique à cause de leur religion
à cause de leur sexualité et l pardon
mais je trouve qu'elle passe son temps à
provoquer ces emplois constamment qu'une
religion c'est de la merde et s'en
prendre à une communauté après faut pas
s'étonner et je ne cautionne pas le
harcèlement des risques et de la
première année mais non mais je suis
désolé menacé de mort est ce que tu dis
ça donc trois noms mais d'accord mais
très bien donc charles ils augurent
aussi grâce à des graphiques sur les ça
c'est de la provocation alors à ce
moment-là charley aussi avait eu des
menaces
ça non mais elle a raison je rate in
national quand on parle de 1000f faut
savoir que même nous en tant que simple
chroniqueur c'est risqué c'est à dire
combien sur dungey box et on peut avoir
très bien ce soir moi j'ai eu hier par
exemple sale [ __ ] crève bon voilà donc
c'est pas sympa mais je pense qu'il faut
mettre ça je suis pas d'accord avec vous
je souhaite qu a pas de raison de
banaliser des menaces de banaliser des
insultes je veux banaliser par exemple
les adresses personnelles
bien sûr comme le monsieur de série on a
mis par exemple l'adresse quand j'avais
parlé d'un problème le problème des
mesnel de l'adresse de l'école de son
enfant trouve qu'il ya pas de raison et
je trouve que c'est bien qu'ils les
sanctions voilà et non voilà donc moi je
n'arrive que des champions mais après
mon effectivement la prison non alors
vous vous dites oui oui gilles verdez
oui je dis oui passionnés oui mais je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que le
cyber harcèlement
le cyber le cyberharcèlement ça tue et
ça peut tuer des gens donc c'est un
procès exemplaire hausse et vos clients
et risquent de payer pour cette nouvelle
loi parce que le gouvernement veut
mettre la vie des gens ça pourrait être
votre fils vous aimez pas d'avis mais
laissez moi juste terminée mais aussi
avec la limite ceci dit moi c'est
terminé
ceci dit moi je le crie je sais c'est le
ser minoritaires
je ne suis pas mis là parce que j'estime
que milla est instrumentalisé que milla
devrais je pense faire un peu silence se
protéger elle-même elle sort un livre là
je ne comprends pas pourquoi elle ne
fait pas attention elle alors attention
il faut sur la liberté d'expression il
faut surtout ni par son contraire et
libère sans laissez moi mais non mais si
j'ai la collision a passé cinq essais
libres mais laissez moi finir violence
illégale à la liberté d'expression pour
milla qui n'a pas franchi les limites de
la légalité mais je trouve que c'est
mais où elle sort un livre elle s'expose
trop je pense qu'on aurait ainsi pour
elle je pense qu'il faudrait la
protection de la sphère intime à
s'indigner de à géométrie variable
il y en
jamais il sur le plateau ce qu'il a
entendu sur son téléphone excusez moi
c'est aussi abominable ce que ce qu'a
dit me l'a alors l'été jeunes peu
importe ce qu a dit mais là c'est
horrible s'est elle aussi elle m'a dit
d'être d'être condamnée et n'oscille
mons est pas illégal ce qu'elle a dit le
bateau s'ils arrêtent vous arrivez gala
oui mais on peut pas on peut pas la
bonne façon pas dire ça que m'est assez
autorisée en france c'est insultant
et là il a raison sur sa jolie avec
bosch bien sûr ça non mais moi je suis
comme chez comme géraldine effectivement
il ya deux choses
il y as que milla tombent sous le coup
de la loi ou pas elle ne tombe pas
visiblement sur le coup de la loi
et puis il ya est-ce qu'on peut au nom
d'un emportements effectivement parce
qu'on peut être horrible et sam et moi
et moi j'ai été heurté par la vidéo et
bien sûr vraiment aimé ça mais c'est pas
parce qu'on ait été blessée qui berça on
appelle aux moeurs qu'on appelle à l'
égorger à l'avionique je pense que ça
aurait été plus malins justement de lui
expliquer les choses à dire c'est vrai
bah oui ça pas été la bonne pédagogie je
suis d'accord c'est que moi je crois
effectivement à la valeur pédagogique de
ce procès pourrait pour dire attention
derrière votre ordinateur quand vous
dites quelque chose que vous pouvez vous
vous croyez que vous êtes le seul et que
ça va être un peut-être tweet un mail
que vous allez recevoir mais peut-être
que la personne va recevoir sans idée
sans nicolas bird écoles il ya eu un
petit tour de pédiatrie je reviens vers
vous moi je pense qu'il faut prendre
conscience des choses à un moment donné
c'est à dire que c'est pas un espace de
liberté qui permet de dire n'importe
quoi à n'importe qui le harcèlement
effectivement tu dans la rue on le
condamne
pourquoi le condamnerait pas aujourd'hui
quand monsieur vous dit ce n'est pas
votre enfant mais c'est pas une réponse
je veux dire à un moment donné moi si
j'ai mon enfant qui harcèlent avec
quelqu'un ou qui menacent de mort ce que
j'espère vous exprimer c'est quand même
extrêmement ses réflexions